Eugene Schwarz is one of the most
prolific copywriters in the world and he
wrote this book Breakthrough Advertising
which is $125
at titansmarketing.com.
And one of the things you learn when
reading the book is that Eugene only
worked three to four hours a day. Yet he
wrote six times as much copy as any
other copywriter in the industry while
he was alive. And the reason he was able
to do that is because he used a
technique called the 3333 method where
he would get a timer and he'd set that
timer for 33 minutes and 33 seconds and
he'd have to sit down at his desk for
333 and he couldn't do anything but
write. He could sit there and do
nothing. He could sit there and stare at
the wall, but if he was going to do
anything, it would have to be writing.
And it just so happened that doing that
five to six times a day, which only ends
up being three or four hours of work,
absolutely obliterated the productivity
of everybody else in the industry, which
is exactly what you should be doing if
you want to write more copy. Set a timer
for 3333. Write some tweets, write some
emails, write a sales letter, whatever
you do, and I guarantee you will destroy
everybody else's productivity in your
niche.